few things cause more offense in america
than criticizing military veterans and
outrage over claims the president
mocked soldiers killed in battle is only
growing
my stepson was not a loser my son is not
a loser
my son matthew is not a loser
it's claimed donald trump canceled a
visit to a u.s cemetery in france
two years ago because he said it was
filled with losers
during the same trip it's alleged he
referred to 1800 u.s soldiers who died
as suckers the remarks made by anonymous
military sources in the atlantic
magazine
have now been independently confirmed by
the associated press
for us these are active duty officers
and if they were
i mean there they don't have a career
after that and so
what i'm interested to see is does john
kelly
speak up does does general matters speak
up
senior members of the military have been
conspicuous in their silence
but veteran pilot and hudson river hero
sully sullenberg tweeted
for the first time in american history a
president has repeatedly shown utter and
vulgar contempt and disrespect
for those who have served and died
serving our country
and donald trump's presidential
challenger joe biden
wasted no time in responding either
my son volunteered
and joined the united states military as
the attorney general
and went to iraq for a year won the
bronze star and other
commendations he wasn't a sucker
the service men and women he served with
particularly those did not come home
were not
losers donald trump has offered an
emphatic denial
there is nobody that feels more strongly
about our soldiers
our wounded warriors are soldiers that
died in war
than i do it's a hoax but comments the
president
previously made about late senator and
vietnam prisoner of war john mccain
have cast doubt over his denials he's a
war hero because he was captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
i hate to tell you the identity of
military sources behind these damaging
claims
remains protected but donald trump is
all too aware
the comments now circling his campaign
are a threat to his re-election sally
lockwood sky news
los angeles